the Joe Rogan experience I saw a lot of
guys get kicked in the face man
how many times you've been kicked in the
head oh I have no idea zero idea a lot a
bunch of times for sure Conchita yeah I
don't know never unconscious from that
never unconscious from anything dropped
from a punch in a fight I got I got a
TKO'd I got dropped him I was like he
hit me in the jaw in my lip it didn't
hurt per se
it wasn't like like sometimes you get
hit in the body like a liver shot it
[ __ ] hurts so bad it doesn't matter
if you're in the middle of a fight it
hurts so bad but the jaw didn't hurt but
my legs just stopped working like the
wind we they just stopped they just shut
off and they went out from under me it
was crazy I don't think I never had it
happen that way before
I definitely been dinged where I like
wobbled yeah I like covered up and
recovered and had that happened before
but I never had it where I just my [ __ ]
just shut off let's just shut off dude
but I was still conscious and that I was
trying to get up and I was like [ __ ]
point point they just didn't work and
then he hit me a couple more times and
it fell again the referee stopped the
fight so that was the worst I've never
been hit in the head
nah but you never enjoyed it out for me
no I was always scared of it you've been
knocked out though no never been never
once no [ __ ] no how many can how many
concussions do you have you think on
record I don't know I have three I have
three I know I think two to one when I
was a kid I think I I know I cracked my
head cuz I have a giant scar back there
above my hair transplant scar where I
cracked my head on this some sewer thing
there was like some crane we were kids
we were running past this thing and
something happened I don't remember
exactly happened but it involve falling
and something slipping and something
hitting me in the head and it hit me in
had pretty [ __ ] hard or I didn't go
unconscious but the whole world went
like yeah I remember I remember saying
to the doctor that I grayed out like a
grayed out but then I came back like so
it was a big impact on my head so was
that time than the time that I got
tko'ed but then the other times in
between it was mostly just getting
dinged
wages pop
and your legs give out a little bit then
you cover up and then you know usually
like it's inspiring you'll stop and it's
if it's in a fight you get a you know
you either you fall down or you get a
standing eight count you know depending
on if you're boxing or kickboxing right
doing but in the gym you just fight gym
guys get dinged and they go down and
nobody does anything to stop it and you
get back up and you're getting hit again
like you really probably probably should
stop the sparring but people are you
know guys are [ __ ] animals animals
and in in a boxing gym when you're
allowed to indulge in that sort of
animal behavior it gets encouraged
especially amongst really good guys
right I had my [ __ ] knees taken out
from under me that's why I had my first
concussion and when he told me about
that basketball right yeah my neck well
on my [ __ ] hardwood basketball floor
and I remember vividly to put two
moments one people telling me to sit
down because your natural reaction
sometimes when you get knocked out like
that the bounce of your head is to get
back up you know and I could so but I
was unconsciously doing it and then I
remember that and then I remember the
paramedics asked asking me to lie down
and I remember saying I'm gonna throw up
and I did I threw up everywhere and
passed out law then woke up in the
hospital I fell on my [ __ ] air rack
and then in [ __ ] junior high got
popped so hard in football I got hit so
hard my dad was like you got your bell
rung I was listening to yeah work those
listened to Bo Jackson he's on the meat
eater podcast this week and he was
saying he wouldn't have his kids play
football yeah that crazy that guy lived
through hell he has a hilarious crazy
story parts of his life but about
getting the one time he got Kayode in a
game waking up and going to the wrong
side and they say hey [ __ ]
you're on the wrong side like and then
he goes over there and then he hears a
gunshot he's and people sees people
Ryan's like who got shot he goes it's
halftime
he thought he was playing the wrong team
he has a hilarious story but it's also
kind of dark
[Applause]